so in this short segment we'll talk
about some relational properties that I
call mapping properties they can also be
referred to as archery on relations this
segment is mostly vocabulary there are a
half-a-dozen concepts in words that are
standard in the field and the one needs
to know to be able to do some discrete
math and so on the applications will
come in the next short segment where we
start applying of these properties to
counting although there'll be a
punchline about counting at the end of
this segment so let's go back or proceed
and remember that a relation is a binary
relation is a thing with three parts
it's got a domain illustrated by as a
here a codomain Illustrated is B here
and relationships an association between
domain elements and code domain elements
indicated by the arrows arrows being
called the graph of the relation and we
already observed one aspect of archery
and arrows that the concept of a
function could be captured by saying
that there was less than or equal to one
arrow out of every element in the domain
that employed that that there was a
unique other end of an arrow out of a
domain point called the value of that
point under the relation which is in
fact a function f so f of green equals
magenta where there is an arrow out of a
green element but in this picture as is
typical not every domain element not
every green dot has an arrow out of it
so this would be an illustration of a
partial function where f of a green
element isn't always defined if there's
no arrow out well the general idea of
our relations pursues this function idea
that basically we're going to classify
relations according to first how many
arrows come out of domain elements
really in three categories the relations
where there's at most one arrow out of
every domain element there's exactly one
arrow out of every domain element
or there's at least one arrow out of
every domain element and symmetrically
we're going to classify
codomain relations with respect to code
domains in the same way relations where
every code domain element has greater
than or equal to one arrow in has
exactly one arrow in or
at most one arrow in is the other part
of the classification and various
combinations of these things have
standard names which it turns out that
you'll need to know so will lead you
through them okay so let's begin with
the idea of a total relation total
relation means there's at least one
arrow out of every domain element so if
you look at this picture it's not quite
total yet because there are two green
domain elements with no arrows out of
them so I've just highlighted them in
red and we can fix this by making them
disappear now I'm left with a total
relation every domain element has at
least one arrow coming out of it so
that's what makes it total another way
to say total is to say that if you look
at the inverse image of the codomain it
is equal to the domain that means if you
take all the arrows that are coming out
of the domain and you turn them around
and then and you look at all the things
that have arrowheads into them it's the
entire domain so that's what our inverse
of B is nice slick way to say it using
relational operators and sets related to
applying relations so total and function
means that there's exactly one arrow out
and that's probably the most familiar
case of functions and lots of fields
just assume that functions are total but
the truth is that there often is not not
total and people aren't careful about it
so let's look at a calculus like example
here's a function J that takes a pair of
reals and returns a real it Maps the
real plane into the real line and the
of it is G of X Y is 1 over X minus y
now the domain of this function G is in
fact all the pairs of reals that's what
it means to say that it goes from our
cross our shorthand R squared to the
codomain are the codomain is the set of
all reals but this G is obviously not
total because 1 over 0 is not defined
which means that on the on the 45-degree
line G is not defined G of our R is not
defined so G in fact is not a total
function even though it's familiar and
and you not worry about partial
functions normally but without you you
wouldn't notice that this was partial
cuz you're not used to paying attention
to that ok let's look at a slight
variation this is function G 0 that goes
from some unspecified domain specified
in a minute to the reals it has exactly
the same formula G of X Y is 1 over X
minus y but now I'm going to tell you
that the domain instead of being all the
reals is the reals except for that 45
degree line I just want to get rid of
the bad points and not worry about them
the minute I do that I have these two
functions relations that have the same
graph but different domains and the
result is that I've removed from the
domain of G all the bad points I'm left
with a total function G 0 ok let's keep
going
the next concept is of a surjection and
that's a relation where there is at
least one arrow into every point in the
code domain there's at least one arrow
into every point in B well again this is
a picture where that doesn't quite work
because there's at least one bad point
there there it is in red that doesn't
have an arrow in so let's fix things
again by making it disappear now I'm
left with a surjective relation or a
surjection that because in fact
everything in the code domain and B has
at least one arrow coming in
everything's the endpoint of an arrow so
likewise we can say in terms of set
operations that are
surjection if and only if the image of
the domain is the codomain or still
another way to say it is if and only if
the range of the function is its entire
code domain remember the range of the
points that are hit
that's R of a it's not always equal to
the code domain but when it is that is
what makes it a surjection alright
injections another version that our
variation on the theme an injection is a
relation where there is at most one
arrow into every element in the
co-domain so looking at this picture now
this is not quite an injection because
there are at least two points here that
have more than one arrow coming into
them that's what keeps it from being an
injection so let's fix that by deleting
a couple of those edges that are
crowding up points and now I'm left with
a situation where in fact everything in
B has at most one arrow coming in and so
I'm showing you a picture of an
injection and the final concept is when
you have all the good properties a
bisection is when you have exactly one
arrow out and exactly one arrow in it's
a total function that is an injection
and a surjection
because it's got greater than or equal
to 1 and less than or equal to 1 and
equal to 1 for all of the domains and Co
domains now there's an obvious thing
about by jek shion's which we'll wrap up
with which is why they're useful in
counting theory because it's clear that
since there's exactly one arrow out of
every element in a there the number of
arrows is the same as the size of a and
since there's exactly one arrow coming
into every element of B the number of
arrows is the same as the size of B and
guess what that means that where there's
a bijection the sets are of equal size
if there's a bisection between two
finite sets a and B that means that
they're the same size